Brian you're here for the film the
inside aren't you tell me about your
role in the movie and I played character
called aim a mo a pretty unsavory
character you know he's a drug addict
alcoholic he's living rough and pretty
terrifying the three characters in there
are pretty full-on you know how do you
kind of prepare yourself as an actor for
a role like that because you say it is
so full on isn't it oh it is yeah you
just have to go to place in your head
and you know imagination that's what
it's acting the imagination comes into
it a whole new perspective then I know
you came to acting a little bit later in
life didn't you new kind of late
thirties and have you found that
experience and there's a lot of guy
who's ahead of me particularly Noreen I
mean I do most of my work in Ireland I
have worked in Italy and the States but
it's hard to break in the night in the
skill I'm chipping away chipping away
and I'll you know getting there for us
for sure the projects are getting better
we can just talk about what you up to
next as well after the inside up to next
I've got to two features to do one
caller last show which is superb it's
it's it's all one location in a house
it's six actors one director who are the
rehearsing for a shoulders going on in
10 days time I'm playing the director
writer he's very sick man
and it's just the relationships are so
beautifully written there Rita Marie
Lala she's an Irish filmmaker who's
writing this on us it's brilliant and
then I've I'm paying a priest an
exorcist priest yeah in October so
something's got me into the horror
because I've got a few as i say i'm
gonna say more horror than are you
enjoying it yeah I I did a film in New
York last month horror and it's called
model hunger it was just it was terrific
because they did the prosthetics the
makeup the whole thing was just and the
actors were just so good
you